[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
eine leckere türkische linsensuppe die
total aromatisch ist und zu jedem wetter
passt die leckere linsensuppe eignet
sich übrigens nicht nur als vorspeise
sondern auch als hauptgang ich es sie
nämlich ganz gerne zum mittag oder zum
abendessen
wir benötigen rote linsen die habe ich
unter fließendem wasser abgespült klein
geschnittene zwiebeln möhren und
kartoffeln
außerdem wasser olivenöl ingwer sowie
knoblauch
desweiteren benötigen wir tomatenmark
und paprika mark und einiges an gewürzen
ich schreibe sie euch unten in die
infobox um euch jetzt nicht zu
langweilen und zeige euch die
zubereitung zuallererst wird das
olivenöl in einem großen kochtopf bei
mittlerer stufe erhitzt dann gehen wir
knoblauch ingwer und zwiebeln hinein und
dünsten sie für einige minuten an
anschließend geben wir tomaten und
paprika mark dazu und dünsten das
ebenfalls kräftig an
wer kein paprika magda hat der kann die
menge auch ganz einfach durch
tomatenmark ersetzen aber das paprika
mark macht es dann doch noch ein
bisschen würziger anschließend geben wir
die roten linsen die möhren und die
kartoffeln mit hinzu dadurch dass das
gemüse in kleine stücke geschnitten
wurde ist das ganze viel schneller weich
und wir können die suppe viel schneller
pürieren
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit habe ich das wasser
aufkochen lassen und gebe das jetzt mit
in mein topf und zwar soviel bis alles
mit dem wasser bedeckt ist
[Musik]
während ich das ganze hier um rühre
warte ich bis es einmal aufkocht damit
wird die nötige hitze erreichen
[Musik]
nun geben wir den deckel drauf und
lassen das und ca 20 minuten vor sich
hin köcheln und dabei bitte nicht das
ungern vergessen denn wir wollen ja
nicht dass uns so etwas anbrennt
[Musik]
nach circa 20 minuten bei mittlerer
hitze dürfte auch alles schön weich
geworden sein
hier seht ihr das sich in der zeit immer
wieder umrühren
denn es kann schnell passieren dass euch
da am topfboden etwas anbrennt
[Musik]
anschließend wird das ganze mit dem
pürierstab gut durchführen
[Musik]
nachdem dann keine stückchen mehr übrig
sind und das ganze schön dickflüssig
geworden ist geben wir unsere gewürze
mit hinzu
die werden jetzt auch noch mal gut und
sorgfältig untergerührt und so ist die
suppe natürlich noch etwas zu
dickflüssig und deshalb geben wir an der
stelle so viel wasser mit hinein bis die
konsistenz uns gefällt und somit ist
unsere 40 türkische linsensuppe auch
schon fertig die linsensuppe schmeckt
übrigens am allerbesten wenn ihr dazu
noch zitrone serviert dann habt ihr noch
eine richtig schöne und traditionelle
säure
ich gebe das noch mal gerne dazu damit
wir das nicht schon im topf haben
sondern erst wenn jeder seinen eigenen
teller hat außerdem es sich dazu über
ganz gerne frisches fladenbrot aber das
ist natürlich vollkommen euch überlassen
zu guter letzt könnt ihr die suppe noch
mit getrockneter minze garnieren und
dann lasst ihr sie euch ganz einfach
schmecken
übrigens gibt es die linz und super bei
mir ganz oft in kombination mit meinen
panierten singapore sechs nicht verlinkt
euch das video mal im anschluss und dann
freue ich mich wenn ihr dort mal
reinschaut euch inspirieren lassen und
natürlich auch im nächsten mal wieder
dabei sein
[Musik]